Failure is not an option. If we get him out, we save millions of lives
Father Chavo, we've got motorcycles on our ass,  I need a new vehicle ASAP
On your left!
This is an overwatch operation
Our team is engaged in a higher form of patriotism
It's not a military operation
The goal is to complete the mission at any cost
We get a week on a beach
You are never going to do something normal until you die. That's what this job is.
I'm not you.
You're pretty close
Besides, this is my Beach
Feel the sand between my toes
Sir, you ever walk in? Who is he? That's my asset. local Special Forces
Sent him to medical to see if he's who he says he is
What is your name?
Li Noor
Are you involved in acts of espionage? Yes
I have information that proves my government is planning an attack on the United States.
You have no idea how evil my government is.
Put me on a plane to the U.S. and I'll give you everything
Stick the drive
You're going up against this country's elite tactical squads
I need him back right now
No one ever enters a war thinking they will lose
But one side is always wrong
I'll give you some advice. You ready?stop
We're on the move
They miss that plan we have failed they miss that plan they are dead
Chat one, expect company
Failure is not an option
We get him out we save millions of lives
Requesting hand of God
Coming down